did you know that there was a dua to cure anxiety mentioning the quran as well
check the description for the full dua the prophet salallahu said as part of this
new oh allah in other words you're asking him to make the quran central a light
for your heart any cure for your anxiety a cure for every problem a relief for
your difficulty take advantage of this powerful dua think about it from beginning to end write
it down repeat it recite it memorize it and it's important in fact to memorize it
and teach it to others as the prophet salallahu advised we ask allah to make the
quran the life of our hearts the light of our chest a departure for all of
our sorrows and a release for all of our anxiety
assalamu alaikum thank you for watching our series if you want to continue learning and benefiting
has a large collection of free ebooks and resources you can download the meta website at
melrose.org forward slash
gifts